لم ينته الشتاء حتى الآن ولكن الربيع
قد يكون بالفعل في الهواء يقول خبراء الصحة إن
الوقت قد حان لبدء الحماية
من الحساسية الموسمية التي
بدأت بالفعل في منع الالتهاب الآن يمكن أن
يساعد ليس فقط في بداية الأعراض
ولكن أيضًا يجعله موسمًا أفضل
توصي فلافيا هويت ، أخصائية الحساسية الشاملة من National Jewish Health ، برذاذ أنفي من
الستيرويد ، وهناك بعض الأدوية التي
لا تستلزم وصفة طبية ، لكن Hoy يقول
للتأكد من أنه من الستيرويد الأنفي ، تحقق مع
طبيبك إذا كنت غير متأكد من أنك
تعرف بخاخين في الحنين على
يساعد الأساس اليومي نوعًا ما على تقليل
الالتهاب الذي يستغرق بضعة أسابيع حتى
يتراكم في نظامك ، وبعد ذلك عندما
تأتي حبوب اللقاح بقوة كاملة ،
فأنت مستعد لمكافحتها ،
يقول بويد إن العلاجات الأخرى التي لا تستلزم وصفة طبية
مثل مضادات الهيستامين سواء كانت
قد تساعد حبوب منع الحمل أو رذاذ الأنف أيضًا بالإضافة إلى
أجهزة الري الأنفي مثل وعاء نيتي ،
والتي يمكن أن تبدأ في وقت قريب من
موسم الحساسية ، لكن المنشطات الأنفية التي
نقول حقًا إنها تبدأ في هذا الوقت من
العام يقول بويد إنه الآن هو الوقت المناسب أيضًا
فكر في منع
البيئة الخارجية من الدخول إلى
منزلك ، وهذا يعني أنه عندما تبدأ في
التسخين ، أبق النوافذ مغلقة في
سيارتك وفي المنزل وتأكد من أن الحيوانات الأليفة
لا تجلب حبوب اللقاح إلى سريرك ، فأنت
تعلم أن حبوب اللقاح تبدأ في الطفو
قبل أن ترى  الأوراق على الأشجار
وبالتالي يمكن أن تصيب الناس على حين غرة من أجل
الصحة ، أنا ماندي غايثر